- Before Joe Rogan was a hit podcast host,
and after Ludacris was a hit rapper,
they were hosts of a show
called, "Fear Factor."
Do not try any of these at home.
I'm watching for medical
accuracy and information only.
Pew.
Oh, oh my God.
(horror music)
Worst fear alert of my life.
Oh my God forget about
the little pinchers.
The tail just going...
(bouncing)
(squishing)
- Calm down, calm down, calm down.
- Oh my God, she has to put them in there?
(horror music)
They're biting her hand, no!
If aliens were ever to come
down to Earth and see this,
they would feel pity on us.
- [Joe] One of you will
be bound by your wrists,
while covered in over 100,000 bees.
- A hundred thousand...
- [Joe] Your partner is going
to have to eat 20 live bees.
- I'm more afraid for the bees.
What did the bees do to deserve this?
Oh my God, I would have a full,
forget panic attack,
this is dangerous.
Getting stung by bees
causes localized inflammatory response.
If you have an anaphylactic
reaction, you could die.
(woman screaming)
- [Joe] Alright, here comes
the first bee down the hatch.
- Oh my God, what happens
when you eat a bee?
Can it sting you or are
those stingless bees?
(chopping)
- [Joe] That's it, nice.
- Okay, she's not out of harm's way yet.
It's not nice.
(buzzing)
How do you get them off of her?
Did she get stung?
Show me a sting.
- [Man] They didn't show
removing them entirely.
- Huh? I wonder.
I wonder if those were stingless bees.
Oh no, being submerged.
Worse feeling ever.
These challenges always
scare the life out of me.
Cause if they like, drown,
they're gonna need life-support quick.
And remember, when you're
doing chest compressions
on someone who's drowning,
very different than
doing chest compressions
for people who are on land.
You only need to do hands-only CPR,
if you find someone down on land.
But drowning, you need
to give rescue breaths.
Start with rescue breaths.
- [Ludacris] Hold on, Marisa's in trouble.
Marisa's in trouble.
- Breathe!
- Oh no.
- [Ludacris] Breathe!
They are struggling to breathe.
- Yeah, it's hard to breathe,
cause all the little things
are going in your mouth.
- [Ludacris] That's two more wing nuts.
- She's just breathing.
She's not even participating in the task.
She's like, I'm just gonna live here.
- Oh (beep), oh (beep),
oh (beep), oh (beep).
- Oh, this is scary.
- I'm literally jumping off a bridge.
- What's about to happen?
- [Woman] I get like a little anxious,
like if I do look down.
- Normal human emotion,
this is not a phobia!
You're hanging off like a spider,
at the bottom of a helicopter,
and you're afraid.
Normal fear.
Nothing medically wrong with this.
(intense music)
(cheering)
- [Ludacris] Now she's
going for the ripcord.
She got the last knot.
(woman screaming)
- Oh what, is a bungee
jump off a helicopter?
That feels dangerous.
Can you imagine if she just like,
(bouncing)
bungee jumped all the
way over the helicopter,
onto the blades.
That would've been evil.
Bungee jumping is dangerous.
Because that recoil can cause
like snapping of the neck,
if it's not secure,
and you know, snapping of
the neck is never ideal.
- Inside this box, are
over 500 bull testicles.
- I watched this episode with my parents
when we came as immigrants from Russia.
And we were like, what
is happening in America?
- On go, your partner is
gonna smash their face
into this box of testicles.
(laughing)
- On nationwide television,
your partner has to smash their face
into a box of testicles.
I don't even know if
there's any harm here,
like medically.
What if the cow had an STI?
Maybe that could be a problem.
Like an epididymitis.
Hmm, this is what an
epididymitis looks like.
- [Joe] Your partner,
will then have to spit out that testicle
into the testicle receptacle.
(record scratching)
- (laughs) Who made?
What five year old made this stunt?
(intense music)
- [Joe] All right, Missy,
she's got a testicle.
(water splashing)
- Oh, going from upside down.
- [Joe] Very nicely done.
- When you're changing position like that,
the blood flow is going to your brain,
then it's going to your
feet, to your brain.
That could be really disorienting.
- [Woman] You got it, we're not losing.
- We're not losing.
This poor dude is getting drowned
with bull nuts in his mouth.
Only in America.
- Go!
- So what are they drinking?
Tomato juice?
- [Ludacris] Habanero.
- Oh, spicy sauce.
- All in there, all in
there, all in there.
- Oh, did he just throw up?
- It tastes like Jean-Claude
Van Damme punched me
in my throat.
(record scratching)
- Jean-Claude Van Damme got
his butt kicked in real life.
At least do like Chuck
Norris or something.
- [Ludacris] Oh, he picked all
really, really hot peppers.
Come on, baby.
So this is gonna hurt.
- [Man] As soon as it got
in my throat, I felt it.
- The capsaicin right there,
is just bounding to the receptors,
making it feel like burning
damage is happening.
You're getting full-on
inflammatory response,
swelling, sweating.
Ah!
- [Man] I can't let him down,
but my body isn't gonna
agree with what's going on.
- Yeah, it's not gonna agree.
And you know what?
It's gonna burn on the way out too.
(gun bangs)
Oh look, there's Bear.
(dog barking)
Oh, that's a scary challenge.
(beep)
Oh my God.
(woman groaning)
I assume that's a puncture proof vest,
but you would still feel the pressure
and get severe bruising.
You could even fracture a bone this way.
(dog growling)
- [Woman] Stop, it hurts.
- You made it through!
- Did she make?
That was the worst anti-climatic ending.
You made it through!
She almost lost her arm.
Bear.
Oh! Right in the bull testicle.
Would you ever bite a
person's arm like that?
I would never do that.
- [Joe] Safety officer will
release a canister of gas.
You must see how long you
can stay in the building.
- Interesting, tear gas.
Okay, so most tear gas isn't actually gas.
It's like aerosolized solids or liquids,
that cause maximal irritation.
It's like, bromo-something,
that cause mucus membrane
disruption, nausea,
visual changes.
There's actually long-lasting
effects to tear gas.
That's why they really
try and avoid using it.
(woman coughing)
Yeah, it's very irritating to the airways.
(woman spitting)
(woman coughing)
Oh, that's gonna hurt, ugh.
You could have a full on asthma attack,
respiratory distress.
Oh, she's gonna need to get washed.
She could throw up, it doesn't end there.
Like she needs to take a
full decontamination shower.
- [Ludacris] One of you will be strapped
into this electric chair.
- Okay, why?
- Four of the five keys
inside that valet box unlocks
a restraint on this chair,
(chains clinking)
freeing your partner.
- And if you don't,
please don't tell me you get electrocuted.
- [Ludacris] If you hit
the sides of this fence,
you will be electrocuted.
- Oh my God, is it like Operation?
The dark version of Operation?
By the way, electrocuted
used to mean electricity
and executed.
So I really hope no one
dies on Fear Factor.
- Every 15 to 20 seconds,
the person inside of this chair,
will be electrocuted as well.
- Stop saying electrocuted,
just say tased.
Electricity is dangerous.
It can stop the heart.
It could cause the heart to fibrillate,
which is not a useful rhythm.
You could actually get skin
burns from electricity.
So it really depends on
the amount of current,
how high the voltage is,
how long it's being
passed through your body.
Also depends if your skin is wet or dry.
Like all those things matter.
- (screaming) Oh my God!
- And she got tattoos before.
So you know she can handle some pain.
- [Joe] In that tank are electric eels,
containing over a thousand volts.
Grab six electric eels,
and transfer them over to
the other side of the tank.
You gotta hold them eels?
Medically, I don't know if this is okay.
Like if my patient said, "Doctor,
I'm here to get clearance
"in order to touch eels
with my bare hands."
I would say, "Please leave
for my office right now."
(water splashing)
- [Joe] You just gotta commit.
- Guys, I'm committing.
I haven't even-
(woman screams)
- This is awkward.
- You're just a big baby.
- He should touch one.
- I wanna feel it.
- Go ahead, grab the big fat one.
Don't touch it.
- Whoa!
- What did I tell you?
Grab it.
- That sucks.
- (laughs) He learned his lesson.
- 30? Is it 30?
- [Joe] Let's go, you got plenty on you.
Come on over.
Now he's gotta suck 30 leeches off you,
before you each eat 10 of them.
One.
Two.
- Ew!
You know, people used to do leech therapy.
And there are some things
leeches are not terrible for,
like so when leeches attach to you,
they release a chemical,
that prevents clotting from happening,
cause they wanna keep sucking your blood.
So that chemical can actually be utilized
for certain conditions.
I don't recommend using
leech therapy on your own.
It's more for scientific
research purposes.
- [Joe] Hurry up!
- You know, what's funny?
I'm acting grossed out by this,
but this is usually how
I spend my Friday nights.
Sorry, Thursday nights (laughs).
What'd you do last night?
Suck some leeches off of my partner.
What'd you do?
Oh, did you guys have dinner first?
No, I ate dinner after.
The leeches.
- [Man] When I was laying in the tub
(rats squeaking)
with hundreds of rats
crawling all over me.
- I wanna know, because I'm a doctor,
and I didn't learn this in school.
What's the difference
between a mouse and a rat?
- [Man] Rats are bigger.
- Oh, what if you have a big mouse?
Like, look.
Look how big this mouse is.
Is this a rat?
Sorry, I had to do that.
(laughing)
- [Man] Thanks for apologizing.
- I felt every single
foot of all those rats.
Oh my God!
- But rats do transfer a lot of diseases.
Leptospirosis, hantavirus.
So many issues.
Salmonella.
Like the bacteria lists are huge.
Bubonic plague.
How did that happen back in the day?
Rats!
- [Man] Can't believe I'm
gonna have to be chained up,
while seeing my brother suffocating.
I hope he doesn't freak out.
- Hold on a second.
Did they just escalate this
and make this 10 times more difficult?
Just going into an enclosed
environment like that,
would instantly trigger
claustrophobia in most people.
Claustrophobia is a specific phobia.
A lot of people have that.
Your symptoms will be
like, nervousness, anxiety,
all the way up to having a panic attack.
And having a panic attack,
for those who's had them,
basically feels like the world is ending.
You can't take a deep breath.
Your heart's racing all over the place.
- [Ludacris] One minute
30 seconds is gone.
- You know, when there's
a stampede at a mall
or sporting event?
The real danger is like
putting pressure on your chest,
so much so that you can't breathe.
That's what I feel like is
about to happen, right now.
- [Man] This is like my
worst fear and like--
- Oh my God.
He's like a human condom right now.
- Hey! All right, okay.
(chains clinking)
- So what happens?
- [Woman] Get your brother!
- Did he just do chest
compressions on him?
He's alive, you don't need to do that.
These are superworms.
I think superworms are actually edible.
And they like contain some decent protein.
Oh, there was an article,
in the New York Times not too
long ago with super worms,
because they can actually
digest styrofoam and plastic,
and maybe they're a solution
to our recycling dilemma.
It's not what I thought I would
talk about on Fear Factor.
Someone's gonna be
power-lifting after this.
(squelching)
- Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
- [Ludacris] Here we go, and time!
- This show is disgusting.
Sadists have created this show.
And somehow all of America tuned in.
- [Joe] You're each gonna
have to walk barefoot,
on this broken glass.
- See, this is more of a mental thing.
So the thing with broken glass is,
I'm gonna give tips.
Ideally, you do this with
wine or champagne bottle,
because it's more curved,
and more gentle, the glass,
than like if you were to use
glass from a drinking glass.
And also, because there's so much glass,
the smaller particles kinda fall through
and allow a sinking sensation.
So when you step,
it's not as bad as stepping
on one piece of glass.
(glass clinking)
Most people don't even cut their feet,
if you're doing it correctly.
(glass clinking)
Yeah, see he's doing the right thing.
He's like separating the
glass to get the edges off.
- [Joe] Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Lift your foot up.
- [Man] Ah, see it's
putting it right in my foot.
- He walked across all this glass,
and it only started to hurt
when he stepped on one piece of glass.
- Our strategy is for me
to try to eat most of the marshmallows.
(beep)
(buzzing)
- What is the marshmallow?
It's a marshmallow covered by bees?
At first, challenge seems doable.
Then you realize the
marshmallows they have to eat,
are covered in live flies.
Flies are gross,
because not only do
they like land on poop,
and then land on your food,
who knows where these flies have been.
Do you know how flies eat?
Like if they land on your watermelon,
flies puke on your watermelon first,
in order to get their
enzymes into the food.
(gagging)
I came so close to throwing up there.
My eyes are watering.
How are they eating that?
I mean, the flies are just protein.
So it's fine.
It just like society has
ingrained this into my mind.
Oh my God, my eyes are watering.
- [Ludacris] Devin is
two marshmallows down.
And Tiona ate one, so five more to go.
- (coughs) I'm not faking this.
Stop showing the zoom-ins.
I'm trying to give you
medical information,
but all I can think about
is not puking right now.
The FDA allows some pretty
shocking things in your food.
Click here to check that out.
As always stay happy and healthy.
This list will surprise you.
Like it surprised me what the FDA said.
Yeah, that's in there.
Cool. What?
(upbeat music)